they're called the Robo Guri Superstars
and it's easy to see why they sing and
dance with unrestrained passion
it's their way of sharing their culture
with us it's a cultural tour but it's
also a sign a clear signal that this
community is ready to welcome visitors
there's a group of gorillas living in
the forest near their town and they hope
tourists will soon be allowed into the
park to visit them
that's because gorilla tourism is this
region's new cash crop it's changing not
only the lives of Africans who live
around Burundi National Park but the
landscape of this country as well
although Uganda is rich in natural
resources
it remained one of the world's poorest
and least developed countries until the
1990s political stability and economic
reforms have turned things around
clearing the way for tourism and new
opportunities these days tourism is the
second largest source of revenue in
Uganda right behind agriculture
seventy-five percent of that money is
being generated by adventurous people
coming to see the gorillas the smokebox
see hundreds at De Anza clinicas Alfred
twinam a journey is a wildlife guide in
the part before this park was visited
people were depending on the tea only as
a source of income tea yeah and that's
it that's it but now the many are
depending on tourism now mostly they
depend on tracking and park entrance
fees it's $250 per person or four
hundred thirty five thousand Ugandan
shillings to track gorillas for a day
plus $15 to get it
a percentage of that revenue goes into
the community's coffers boosting incomes
and funding projects like new schools in
this country where the average income is
only about three hundred dollars a year
a little bit goes a long way the money
spent here boosts the conservation of
the endangered mountain gorillas tourism
makes the animals valuable resources
thank you and gives local people
incentive to preserve them guide may dad
has worked here at the park since it
opened the tourists said bringing money
to the country so the people who are
benefitting from tourism they also
continue protecting them that's what
it's all about benefits for the locals
respect for the animals and as long as
tourism is managed carefully the
gorillas may have a better shot at
survival and local people like the
robber Guri superstars will have reason
to hope and real cause to kick up their
heels and celebrate
you